I don't know what you made Dustin but
this is a new episode about copying
Commerce which I'm really excited here
with my partner in crime
Zubin and we have a wonderful guest room
and please say hello and intro our
tremendous tremendous guest thank you so
much thank you guys I'm so happy to be
here with you guys personally so mano
why don't you tell everybody why don't
we spend the first five minutes creating
the context of this of this show of what
uh your journey how we how we got here
yeah I mean so I had a really
interesting journey I studied finance in
university and when I first graduated I
kind of took your kind of typical Middle
Eastern career path of like fulfilling
your parents dreams of having you know a
really stable career so I went into
banking I got an investment banking job
and you know I just found myself feeling
very unfulfilled and I really felt like
I was always longing for more and you
know I only gave it about a year and
you're into it I was just like you know
what I spoke to my dad I was like look I
really know that you want me to be you
know doing something that's very stable
and assured because my father had very
humble beginnings and for him like
seeing his children have like a very
stable career path where he was
guaranteed you know the very basics was
very important to him so when I went to
him and I was just telling him like you
know what Dad I just can't do this
anymore I don't feel like this is for me
I need to try to do something of my own
I think I terrified him and and it was
very challenging for my parents to
accept but I knew ultimately it was
something that I really needed to do I
always struggled feeling like I was a
part of an organization where I wasn't
able to have a big impact and I wasn't
able to act on creative ideas that I
wanted to to create or any sort of other
ideas that I wanted to have I just felt
like there was so much bureaucracy which
I hated and I still try to make sure
that we don't have that in our
because for me is just something that I
feel is really damaging to someone's
dreams and passion and and their
enthusiasm so I just I got really sick
of the corporate world I quit my job I
was only about 24 years old and I
actually had no plan at all I didn't
know what I was gonna do I was just um I
was just you know figuring things out
one step at a time a friend of mine was
like let's start a PR agency together so
he created an agency and I did that for
about two three years and I was
basically just self-employed trying to
cover my bills what was the biggest
thing you think you learned pro about
yourself and things that you had to work
on by having that first chapter I think
the pro like the positive part of myself
that I learned was I'm definitely like a
very optimistic person throw anything
towards me I can solve problems I'll
never give up like I will go to the end
of the world to find a solution and
actually like many solutions to one
problem so I never give up I think my
biggest challenge that I had in that
stage of my life in my 20s was really
the ability to say no know when to raise
my standards to challenge people and be
really direct with people I had a I had
an issue kind of being like okay well
this is how much you're gonna pay me for
this and I just had a challenge being
super direct asking this conversation of
money was the challenge conversation of
raising your prices once you got
comfortable with the price point was a
challenge it was a big challenge and I
almost felt guilty asking for people to
pay me for their services and it was
just a really weird stage of my life and
I think I've through therapy have
understood it more it's just like a
weird thing that I feel like I've always
associated money with guilts like I felt
bad spending money I thought that asking
for money um so I didn't really know my
worth which is definitely something that
I look back and I'm like oh I only knew
that sooner you know I would have been
in a very different stage but again I'm
so happy things worked out the way they
were
so that was an early stage of my career
was just being when being an
entrepreneur was being self-employed
being a consultant I did PR for about
three years and then I ventured into my
own beauty salon which definitely taught
me
it was a dream at the time I'm obsessed
with beauty I'm obsessed with pampering
I'm obsessed with making people feel
good about themselves I used to love
seeing people come in and leaving just
to feel transformed I loved giving women
that confidence and then but it was a
ladies only salon but I love seeing
people's feel like very confident and
that transformation really really
invigorated me and it made me get just
over the moon um so then my sister my
sister had and I are super-close he met
she was a makeup artist at the time and
then I remember just thinking about it
one day because I'd see her so
passionate and she was doing doing so
many great things with just her makeup
artistry and I remember a lot of my
friends were actually her clients and
they'd always come to me and they'd be
like well I really want to get your
sisters lashes like where do you saw
them and I kept having to tell them like
sorry we don't sell them these are ones
that she creates by hand she's cutting
them up she's creating lashes herself
and I kept remembering that question
over and over again like I'm like why do
I always get this question about her
lashes then I was like why can't we
create them it can't be that hard so it
was like kind of an epiphany and I was
like let's create a brand together and I
asked her if she'd be interested and she
was like absolutely if you think we can
make it happen and I was like we can
make anything happen you know if we have
a vision we can make it happen but I
just want to know that you are into this
because this is really for you
and she was obsessed with the idea and
then we just you know started googling
every lash manufacturer in the world we
started getting samples and before you
know it I mean obviously it took a lot
of sweat blood and tears we found the
right manufacturer and we begged Sephora
for over a year to take us on and after
like a year of constant persistence they
finally you know had the confidence to
launch her brand and Dubai and that was
about yeah that was 2013 and you know
seven years later now we're and also for
is in the u.s. we ran all over Europe
Asia Pacific Middle East North Africa
you know we've got a huge presence you
know so it's it's pretty magical how
things started and now we have three
global offices we have an office in
Dubai an office in the UK we have office
in LA and yeah we're creating we have
three brands now we have Hooda Beauty
which is
the color cosmetics brand we have que le
which is the fragrance friend and we
also have wishful which is a skincare
brand and we have over 250 awesome
employees I love that that's what
everybody needed that's listening so we
need that yeah so you know we kind of
talk about the past in passing
essentially like Investment Banking PR
etc how much of that helped you and
helped you initially it helps you now as
you run this global organization yeah I
mean I think it was every single kind of
experiment that I had I mean I was a
serial entrepreneur so I dabbled into so
many different things and I think every
single bit of experience I had helped
because initially it was just hood of
myself my sister Elia for the first
couple of years it was just three of us
and then we finally had enough money to
hire a PA but attention I'm sure
interrupt because I think this will help
a lot of people and to be frank I'm
always 100% focused on who's watching
and listening what was the biggest
challenge in working with family in that
environment like you know like I think
so many people I get asked a lot because
I worked with my dad and that worked my
brother and and a lot of people really
struggle with this would give me like
three to four hot takes on things that
you learned and continue to learn it
family life because now you're adding
another sister something okay you you
really lived it what uh what what was
the hardest and what was what's
something you're you're collectively so
much better at today than you were years
ago well when I first started I used to
struggle a lot with my sister Hannah
because we have like polar opposite
personalities and I just I would just
always disagree with her a really close
amazing because about eighteen months
apart so like if she'd say you know the
sky was blue I'd be like it's it's off
blue or whatever like we'd always like
argue with each other and we waste a lot
of time just kind of like deciding who
is right and I think a lot of it had to
do with ego and trying to prove who
more or whatever but when I really
started to appreciate the differences
that we have between herself and even my
sister alia and even had his husband
Chris who joined us after a couple of
years when I really start to appreciate
how they were different to me and try to
see things from their point of view it
really gave me a lot of perspective they
gave all this perspective and I think
that we all made collectively better
decisions because we were thinking from
a very different perspective so I think
really like drop your ego doesn't matter
who's right you all have to like work
towards a vision you know you all want
to succeed and make it something much
larger than yourself like for us
initially I think when we first launched
the brand it was about solving a problem
there's no great lashes in the market it
was a challenge it was exciting but I
think after three four years and I think
really after we got our evaluation and
we got our investors on board and we had
the opportunity to sell the company for
over a billion dollars and after that
stage it became like it when we declined
the offer you know we were like okay
this is so much more than the money it's
now this is like about deep meaningful
you know issues we want to solve
together about changing the world as
much as we possibly can together how
about disrupting the industry and also
creating an incredible company for
people to have their dream jobs that we
never had you know so um so yeah I think
just appreciating each other and
learning from each other and having no
ego and communicating better I think I
personally used to struggle a lot with
communication if I was upset I'd be kind
of passive-aggressive and now I'm not
I'm like now as soon as somebody makes
me a little bit upset I like make a note
so I'd make sure to go back to it later
and I don't forget it or shove it under
the rug and then explode on them later
and like upset them I think a lot of the
things drastically yeah I think a lot of
the things that I've learnt is like
really a lot to do with psychology like
I think get a good interpersonal skills
I mean running a business is about the
people a hundred percent percent I mean
the reason I bought suit the reason I
bought subin's company over the other
companies that I could have looked at
was my belief in how he manages humans
yeah and who and who he is as a human
it's every driven
yeah no I appreciate that you want to
talk to us a little bit about your
go-to-market strategy because you were
as you mentioned like you begged Sephora
to get in you finally got in to Sephora
and dubai talked us through that path
all the way through basically having the
online experience you have right now and
let's come and talk a little bit about
that and go down that alley of being
like being an omni-channel brand selling
online selling in retail how did all
those move in and where are you now so
um I think again like we're so lucky
that things happen the way they did we
had a blog before we actually launched
the brand so had Ahad hoodie be calm way
before we even had the thought of
creating a brand so we had the audience
already there it was kind of like a
dream come true for any sort of like
business um so we had an audience who is
ready for the product that we were going
to launch and they were there watching
closely and we started off very small we
lunched I'm sorry we launched in one
door we were launched in Sephora Dubai
Mall which I think was a great thing
because we focus we drove all the
traffic that's by the way on the record
because I've been to that's Dubai Mall
like just for everybody around the world
that's one big [ __ ] door you know it
was one door but it's like it's like 800
doors
yes that's huge by the way when I
apologize ooh man everyone's completely
freaking out in the comments that you're
balling super low so you fix that or
they're gonna continue to scorch you
there you Barry
go ahead so yeah so we launched in
Sephora did my mom one door you know we
drove all the traffic there and I think
in retrospect that was a great strategy
we built up crazy demand we were
constantly dealing with stock issues
because we of course didn't know how to
forecast we had no idea what kind of
demand there would be but that went on
for about six months to a year and then
we expanded to all of the Middle East
Sephora doors um and then it was about
another year and a half we launched in
Harrods in the UK so that was our first
you know door out of the region and we
were continuously begging for Sephora us
to take the brand and it took a very
very long time you know
initially they were like okay you're a
lash brand out of the Middle East like
why do you think you're gonna have a
demand and the United States but I
really think it was the power of social
media that they underestimated at the
time because I think that was still
before the time of people saying these
explosive social media brands really
take off and when we launched in the
u.s. they were really shocked by the
amount of demand that we had there and
you know in all honesty we just kept
growing our page and it was just a
natural thing like the more we grew the
more we expanded the more audience in
our community grew and we were able to
go pretty much global I mean we're in
all areas except Africa certain parts of
Africa and South America but we have a
very big global presence and such a
short time in comparison to all the
legacy brands and you know that had
taken like basically decades to build
themselves so I really especially from
that beginning that you had the hood of
beauty comm blog at what point did you
start actually selling product online
after being Sephora and then how and
this is a very selfish question and how
did who to think about navigating those
early days was there any kind of
blueprint or anything that kind of
inspired some of her executions um yeah
so we had the blog we launched it in
April 2010 and we launched the product
in February 2013 so it was quite a few
years and we were going hard hooda was
going hard she was blogging herself on
her own about three posts a day on top
of doing makeup makeup every single day
so she was really running the show
almost on her own I was helping from
like a business strategy perspective and
doing her PR and everything but when it
came to really the the vision and just
the the way the strategy to launch it I
do have to say it's completely hood as
vision you know she is a visionary she's
an artist and she's got a really
incredible creative vision and also a
great vision when it comes to leadership
so she always thought big from day one
you know for her it was always like how
do we go global how do we make everybody
in the world relate to our products how
do we serve everyone
so it really did come from pedo I I
think she has the natural intuition for
it
but we also love to read books we love
watching people like yourself
we love self-development and I've been
obsessed with it since I was a teenager
so for me it's something that I've
always been inspired by people like
yourself so we were always pushing
ourselves to grow and I think we've
learned from people who've done it
before us like like yourself Gary you
know you're awesome so well but but you
know what's so exciting about it hooda
know we're talking about how she read
crush it and what she got from it what's
so exciting for me now is to watch how
many people I'm even in the comments
right now how many people getting value
out of me it's just good and karma and
sharing positive practical real things
is what's so beautiful about the
infrastructure we now live in and and
and it's it's it's what's really
fascinating and what zoomin what I love
about their execution it's harder to do
this now because companies like your
zoom in hours together Vayner commerce
eliminates the friction of go to market
in a way that wasn't in place when Mona
and Hooda were building their business
definitely not when I was building mine
like you actually almost had to ten
years ago build a blog and a Twitter
account at YouTube for two years before
you could even imagine you know there is
no doubt in my mind that there's people
that for six months winning on tik-tok
can go right into the inner commerce
create a product and do extremely well
it's just so different even already and
we're both young in our careers and it's
already a totally different world in a
lot of ways I wonder if you know Mona
and Hooda and I had the advantage of
building a true community overtime
before we went not that the new tik-tok
regime isn't but we got to sit with it
for a while and know what they wanted
versus what I think you see a lot of now
which is six months a huge oh [ __ ] I
need to make money besides brand deals
let me make a hoodie or let me slap my
name on some [ __ ] and you didn't have
time to R&D it research and develop it
live with it and and the product I mean
it took me forever to launch empathy you
know like like I said like in essence
from the first episode of well it took
me you know
thirteen years to launch a product Wow
you know I've had businesses but a
product and so I sit with it and so I I
think I wonder if you do you agree with
that Mona do you think that the time of
cultivating that community mixed with
you know who does vision and your
understanding of the products that you
wanted to put out that there was a lot
of value in that patience time
absolutely I completely agree with you
and I also think that you know we were
working at a time where I think it was
harder in some ways because we didn't
have the crazy social media exposure you
know there wasn't there was no Instagram
there was no snapchat there was no tik
tok around when we first started but I
think that this space was less crowded
for these uber ly passionate people who
are pumping out lots of constant content
so I think that the advantage was if you
were authentic and if you were
persistent and consistent you'd grow
your following bigger faster we're now
like you're competing so hard to be one
of the many instagramers who have
millions of followers or than many to
stalkers who also have millions of
followers there's just so many people
right now and everybody is capitalizing
off their product because of success
stories that they've seen and everybody
wants to kind of jump on it quick by the
way break breaking news India bans
tik-tok in its class out have been 59
Chinese base I'm just reading the
headline so I don't know if I just read
it right before I went on to see it
again like pretty intense like it's
going to be a very interesting decade
with the allergy and just yeah just one
thing to lean back on the community I
think that to Gary's point at the time
that Gary was building his community you
were building your community obviously
those platforms didn't exist but you
were able to build the community you
wanted and you were able to create the
content that you wanted to create I
think part of the challenge now is like
people are creating content based on
what they think people want which is
fine
but they really need to lean into what
matters to them and and even those
people on tik-tok Instagram whatever it
is the ones that get genuine following
that will leave the platform for them
mm-hmm are because they do something
that matters to them in the matter
kind of the people that are watching so
I think it's that gap of like you do it
on ticked off you do it on Instagram but
getting that person to leave and join
you on your own site is a big gap that
exists but again like it goes back to
the community that you built and the way
you've been able to activate them which
still works today it just takes a lot of
effort yeah absolutely I know you're
spot-on and I've just recently started
my new YouTube channel and I'm trying to
do things that I'm trying to take away
what I think people want me to produce
and just do what I really want to create
and it's challenging like a lot of the
things that I'm creating that have
nothing to do with beauty
you know the engagement slow but I'm
like I'm gonna keep going because it's
what I really want to talk about I'm but
you're absolutely right way I think
we're always constantly like there's a
background voice kind of telling you
okay that's not gonna perform well that
will and you kind of second-guess
yourself but I think the people who are
creating incredible you know visionary
content are people who are just doing
what they want to do two things that I
want to add to show Zubin I apologize I
don't how many questions you have for
this format obviously we're all improv
all the time and I have a little bit of
a issue so I'm gonna have to jump a
little early before our times up here
alright the ton of great questions
coming from people that are watching
live Zubin do you want at some point for
Dustin to throw up questions in here
might be a good idea because I think you
have them agree a lot of people yeah it
doesn't mean you do it
Dustin maybe at 1:35 when I transition
out you can go into some Q&A but fair
enough
are there yes I was I just wanted Gus
thing I just want the four corners
there's just no balance before I bounce
out of here where do you see the biggest
opportunity in attention to build brand
awareness for your brand right now from
your perspective one lady's point of
view obviously a very large size company
compared to most of ours where do you
see an opportunity right now which
platform which execution weather shopper
marketing whether it's advertising
whether it's a country given the global
scale like if I said you hey we have the
better you know if I was on the board I
was like hey we gotta bet the farm on
something right now we're you know let's
uh
what do you what do you want to put
these couple of like targets or what are
you looking at what are you seeing maybe
they can bring some value well that is
definitely a tough question because from
a platform perspective I do think it's
really challenging right now of course
we are investing in tik-tok a lot as you
are you know you're a big inspiration I
know you're going hard on tick-tock
there's so much it's so much you know
somebody just asked so Knapp what if the
US bands tick-tock I'm like then it's
banned for everybody and we all move
somewhere else but all the people that
took advantage of gaining awareness and
community doesn't go away they find them
on you know Instagram or Twitter or
things that nature so I think people
forget how brand works like I don't care
a bind went away I gained a lot of
awareness on that platform which made
with me somewhere that's why that stuff
matters because all of these platforms
probably won't be the platforms in 15
years we've seen it with Friendster and
MySpace and things that nature so okay
tick tock ah yeah I'd probably say from
for us it's probably a Territories
perspective so I'd say China Asia South
Korea those are areas we're really
focusing on right now I think that you
know their economy is clearly doing
really well and I think there's a lot of
room in that market to grow um so that's
a huge focus for us but it's a different
world and they have different social
media platforms that were basically
starting from scratch on so it's it's
definitely challenging but I think
there's a huge opportunity there yeah
well I want to ask you something so what
we've seen obviously retail online and
everybody saying retail needs to evolve
retail needs evolve and come closer to
digital they need to be experiential so
on and so forth and not much
conversation about what digital needs to
do to become more personal
one of the things that I found really
cool on your site were your one-to-one
virtual consultations with your pro
artists can you tell us a little bit
about that because I think it really
humanizes the brand and brings somebody
much closer to that retail interaction
that they kind of maybe long for well to
be honest this was an amazing idea that
came from our senior leadership team and
it was really initially only to help
preserve any job that might need to be
cut so we're like
how can we make sure that everybody is
still staying productive and how how can
we make sure that all the teams that
normally work in store are still busy so
we just wanted to make sure that we
didn't let go of any single people and
we still haven't to date since you know
the coronis Corona pandemic started we
haven't let go of anyone so we wanted to
we you know resource them in a different
way so we decided to have these
consultations online and you know they
we definitely have a lot of learnings
and I definitely take your feedback to
the team so thank you for that I think
that we weren't very direct in the whole
process and like whether it was paid for
but it's still something that we are
trying to work on there hasn't been a
huge demand for yet but I think it's
something that we're going to need to
evolve and keep growing and I think that
all beauty brands are definitely going
to need to jump on to this because I
think even after the pandemic kind of
slows down and things settle and go back
to normal I think people are going to
get comfortable just shopping from home
and they're gonna want to have that
experience at home totally and I think
that what's remark about it remarkable
about it is what everybody kind of
listening can take from it right so this
is something that anybody even if you're
one person starting a brand online you
can learn something from this so what
happens is you go to huda beauty calm
and you can click this virtual
consultation link and it basically gives
you a list of individuals that you can
book and you can book a fifteen minute a
thirty minute 60 minute getting ready
with an artist latch application
whatever it is and then you actually get
access to that person for free
complimentary for that period of time
and they sit with you on some sort of
zoom interactive call and walk you
through it and I think it's phenomenal
because it's really taking service and
what you expect in the best of retail
right in the best of retail you want to
deal with somebody who's actually giving
you value teaching you something so
you're applying that to digital again if
you're just one person you make your
calendar available you block off how
many how much time you have each day for
this sort of thing make it available on
your site build that one-on-one
interaction I mean I think it's again
it's fantastic that a brand at your
skill is doing it and I think that
anybody again even a single person who's
running a business should be doing
something like this it's great thank you
so much we're definitely working on him
but it was it was a phenomenal idea from
our our team and I think it's just great
to make sure that we protect people's
jobs as you know they're the retail has
slowed down so much we just want to make
sure they're busy and they're feeling
productive and also so they feel excited
about what they're doing if they're even
if we were able to keep them just
working from home like it's very
demotivating not to have that
interaction so it's been a great step
for us and we see that the team's also
really happy to be used like that
what about audio before I bounce out
Troy's Ruben you thank you for the setup
what uh what about audio
you know pre-roll podcast original
podcasts Alexis skills what if anything
are you seeing with that and the beauty
space it's it there isn't that much
audio only podcast I think just because
it's such a visual topic but I
definitely think there's space for that
there's a few great podcast that I
listened to you a fat mascara I'm not
sure if you guys have heard of it but
it's great but I definite
unlocked territory and I think that it's
it's interesting code and I have talked
about doing a podcast together and I'd
love to I don't know if it would
necessarily be on beauty particularly
I'd like to explore their topics but
it's not very popular in the beauty
space I think it's just a super visual
community and you know all the platforms
that are attractive to Beauty er are
pretty visual its Instagram is probably
the number one performing platform for
Beauty still it's by announced tomorrow
see now by now what what about what
about the how much do you think about
customizable landing pages at scale from
content where the conversion may be
greater because of the context of the
landing page to you know the ad that's
come in kind of the dynamic web kind of
thoughts any any thoughts about that is
it something of a focus just curious
yeah we are testing different
experiences for different users to see
if there are any differences but to be
super honest soon to be very transparent
we never really had our e-commerce in
the forefront and chilled recently
only because we really didn't have an
a-team until recently it's only been
about - almost almost two years since
we've had a proper EECOM team so we're
really building it up now and after you
know we were just so busy just keeping
the business together
priority but now you know post pandemic
it's really become a huge priority for
us because we realized like you can't
always rely on retailers and you really
do want to try to own that customer
relationship so it's become very very
important and we're working on making it
a more customized experience I love it
i I'm I'm gonna leave it at that I'm
just been reading so many too comments I
think there's so much good stuff coming
it's great to see you again
Zubin taken away thanks for having me
thank you Carrie okay let's do this Mona
doesn't feel free to drop in questions
and then we will share Mona's wisdom
with everyone your sister Mona what are
you uh what is your talk about your
YouTube a little of all the questions
come in and your podcasts and whatnot
yeah so I just started my youtube
channel in February and it's been
something that I think I've been putting
off for a very long time
only because I wasn't sure of the
direction I wanted to take it into and I
was like I'm not a makeup artist I'm not
beauty guru I like business and I do
love beauty but I'm not like a
professional so I didn't feel
comfortable putting myself in that box
and then I'm also like a perfume lover
I'm a perfume addict and I you know
worked on creating the brand the
fragrant friend we have but I didn't
feel good putting myself in that box
either so I kept kind of pushing myself
around and I was like I don't want to
fit into a box and then I was like you
know what why am i trying to put myself
in a box when I tell everybody else not
to and I was like let me just create my
channel I'm gonna create content about
things that I care about and it doesn't
have to be one particular topic and I'm
just gonna experiment it and see how it
goes and it's really been something
that's purely out of passion it's not
for any other reason and I do want to go
more into the direction of self-help and
mental health and things that are going
to help motivate people and help people
and I think that I just feel like you
know I've
had great fulfillment from business but
now I want to fulfill myself from like a
very personal perspective and like a
higher higher meaning perspective so
that's what we mean by my channel but I
think if Gary is any indication I mean
you've seen the comment you see how much
engagement he gets all all over it's not
just on one topic I mean he's just super
broad and he talks about everything he
talks about life personal development
this that the other and I think you've
got a lot to share and maybe don't worry
about having to focus on one area or
another just talk about what you know
and what you are passionate about and
it'll come I mean you'll we're all
figuring it out right like I have the
same problem I go on Twitter and like
okay I don't really want to tweet about
e-commerce so what did you do add this
that D like what am I going to focus on
absolutely absolutely like I always tell
people not to put themselves in a box
and like just be yourself if you feel
good doing this do that if you feel good
doing something else do that too and you
don't need to confine yourself into some
sort of box but I was doing it to myself
so I've decided not to do that anymore
and I'm like you know what just do
whatever makes you feel good and if you
feel like helping anyone at all and it's
totally worth it love it
okay so first question Mona John
Rodriguez asks what do you see in the VR
retail commerce space I'd love to have a
discussion about this thank you John
yeah I mean I definitely think there's a
lot of room to to grow and the VR retail
commerce space um you know it's really
challenging because I think with makeup
of color cosmetics people do really want
to feel and touch the product for me as
a fragrance lover I do think that
there's so much that we can do maybe we
can share kind of like what a fragrance
smells like in terms of like a picture
you know like if you smell a fragrance
you can some you can smell sunshine
almost like a solar effect you can smell
brightness you can smell the beach so
you could just paint that picture almost
but it is really challenging I think we
have to go and hone in on like the ASMR
effect and kind of go full throttle so
like if you're sharing like eye shadow
kind of show how the textures are going
to look what people hear it really
loudly let them
feel like they're there with you likes
watching it live I think it depends on
the industry it's it's really hard and
if I'm honest I don't think anyone's hit
the nail on the head yet especially in
beauty totally you're right and I think
that like over the last few years I
remember CES maybe it was like two or
three years ago there were all of these
mirrors that you could basically get for
your home oh yeah you could yeah you
could basically see what it looks like
different types of lipstick different
kinds of eyeshadow whatnot but not
everybody has access to that and then
their filters and whatnot but I think
that to your point it's more than just
what it looks like on you it's that
feeling that's missing I'm like a VR
perspective yeah and to be super honest
like from everything that I've tried so
far I haven't found anything that
actually reflects like true color or
true texture so I think it's still very
very challenging and I think that this
is my personal opinion I think that
people need to stop going hard onto VR
and think about innovating samples you
know I think let's go back to basics and
think about how do you actually get
samples to be more affordable to get
them into the hands of more customers I
think that that will probably have a
better ROI and the beauty space anyway
I'm not talking about fashion or
anything but I think that we really need
to go hard on giving customers a better
experience with that that's awesome just
to go back to the previous question
before this one and then we'll get a
status question it was what marketing
channels were the most effective for you
or what channels online were the most
effective to building your community
when you first started um I would
definitely say Instagram really helped
the brand explode I think beforehand
when we had our blog when we had
Facebook it was great we had a great
community but when Instagram took off I
think it was really huge especially for
the beauty community because I think
they also took over a huge part of
Instagram I think that like 20 percent
of Instagram photos are makeup tutorials
and hair tutorials and nails so it's
really something that exploded on
Instagram and yeah I definitely would
say that it was the platform that really
helped us skyrocket our growth so Stacia
asks do you believe in scaling up tiny
nisha
they can carve into the beauty industry
so like lip products for darker skin
tones etc um I definitely think so I
mean I'm all about niche brands whether
it be for color cosmetics or fragrance
or skincare I think that you know
there's a lot of people who are still
very underserved and I think that it
would be great to try and scale to serve
those people in different parts of the
world I think it's hard to scale a niche
brands because of course it's not as
profitable when your niche but I think
it's very meaningful and I think the
people who do end up buying your
products and loving your products will
be super loyal and they'll be your
biggest advocates because they were so
underserved so I definitely think it's
worth exploring and I think it should
get the attention it deserves totally
one just one thing I want to add to that
is the word scale is such an interesting
concept because it really means
something different to everybody
somebody wants to scale something small
and get it to a million in revenue here
somebody wants to get it to a hundred a
billion whatever it is so I think that
like to answer seichas question as you
mentioned like yeah definitely do it and
then I think it's important people to
understand what it is they're looking at
chief like what what is your goal and
you can get to that point in scale and
you can have a great lifestyle and you
can have a great business because it's
not just about that top-line revenue
it's all right lifestyle you want to
have to your earlier point about mental
health like where do you want to be in
your life what makes you happy and if it
makes you happy to do that and you can
live the lifestyle you want to lead then
yeah that's the right amount of scale
for you I think focus on the problem
like if you're trying to serve you know
that sort of skin type problem like
focus on finding all the people in the
world that have an issue and solving it
for them and if you do that you'll
naturally scale you know so I think just
make sure it's purposeful and all you
know the business will come entirely
agree with you so Gustavo munos Castro
asks how have you done differently due
to the pandemic opportunities and
challenges well we definitely had to
look at all of our lunches that we had
lined up for the year and we had to be a
little bit more strategic we had to
scale back on some of the lunches and
prioritize kind of what we call our a
launches and look at you know moving
back to 2x to 2021 are like C and D
lunches and even canceling them because
you know we just have to make sure that
whatever we do bet on me bet big and we
bet really focused so that was
definitely a big change for us I think a
huge part of it was also just working
with our team and being able to stay in
touch with them and make them feel
appreciated making them feel like they
were in touch with us and we were all
communicating well I think we are very
you know we're a very loving company and
there's a lot of energy in the company
and as soon as you enter the office
everybody feels each other's presence so
to not have that was definitely
challenging initially but we've just
mastered communicating on platforms like
teams and also just reaching out to each
other calling each other more and just
you know making sure that we are still
connected even though we are virtually
connecting right now and just making
sure that people understand the main
vision of the company I think that it
was a great time to really tell the
company and also our community what
we're really about so it was a time that
we just kept you know reinstating what
is our vision what is our mission why
are we here you know even if there was
no business today why are we still going
to stand here and keep going you know
what do we want to do and it really is
to transform the industry
you mentioned earlier in terms of the
opportunity I mean one of them was just
the fact that you were able to take your
employees that perhaps were in retail
and and bring them into the whole
virtual consultation world yeah there's
so many opportunities of pivot like that
it's just a matter of having the
opportunity and the time and the ability
to do it and really just to think about
to your point we see this so often
recently where organizations that are
doing incredibly well crushing it in
retail like yours and then doing quite
well online never really focused on that
online channel as much as they are over
the last three to four months and I
think that and of itself is a major
opportunity so digital Ethan asks what
is your opinion of text message
marketing do you think we will have a
number
like emails nowadays um multiple numbers
um to be honest I personally on a
personal level I hate text message
marketing so I never even opened them I
just delete them as soon as I see them
so I'm not really a fan I know it's very
different in the US but in Dubai is just
it's it's not something that I see very
beneficial I think that people kind of
expect those kind of emails via email
and I think that when they come via text
people are not usually happy with it so
I feel like just go a route where a
customer already expects it to come so
they're not disappointed and I yeah if
you're gonna if you're gonna come into
their life in one of the most intimate
ways give them something meaningful I
think there are two examples of text
message marketing that I appreciate one
is Gary's wine text so you basically
sign up for wine texts and they send you
wine offers and they're they're great
deals etc and there's a limited supply
so the sense of urgency is there that
works well and then the other thing is
getting notifications on shipping or
getting notifications on things that
you've already purchased so not like
trying to upsell you or sell you all
right you just give you an update I
think those sorts of things make sense
but you're - yeah it's cheesy I think if
it's something you subscribe to it's
fine but it's like when you get these
spam marketing texts I'm like I just I
said buy them I'm like I'm gonna change
my number so I prefer like an email
versus like it text like a text for me
is like something I expect my family
friends to contact me on but when it's a
company I'm just kind of like oh I don't
I don't want to get that from you
totally with you um we shall be no tasks
how do you handle bad reviews online on
your channel page um I almost love
seeing reviews positive and negative and
when I get a negative review I'm just
like let's dissect it let's see if it's
offensive authentic if they have good
feedback
I think feedback it should be your best
friend and when people give you negative
feedback just appreciate it and as long
as they're not doing it just to be nasty
I mean sometimes you can tell people are
doing it just to be nasty
um you know that's a different story but
when they're giving
you feedback to improve your product
think of it as a blessing it you're
lucky they're telling you because a lot
of people who don't tell you what they
don't like they just don't buy your
product again so I appreciate all
feedback it's awesome
Billy Snax asks what advice do you have
to do limited-edition drops
I think limited-edition drops are
definitely powerful especially if you
tie up with the right brand or
influencer and it can be a great way to
really move product and gain awareness
and also gain other communities that you
didn't have touch you know in touch with
before so I think it's great but I think
you do have to be really careful when it
comes to forecasting and also in terms
of making things seasonal you know we've
done things in the past where we made
things like a summer product or a winter
product and we realized you kind of like
box yourself into something where you
know you're in trouble if you eat over
forecasted so I think be careful with
seasonal products but I think
limited-edition where it's a collab with
a brand that you love you should similar
ethos but a very different community
it's great for you to grow your
community yeah and so I'm just gonna
lean in on that last point they just
mentioned so I think that's really the
big opportunity with limit edition drops
not just for your own community but to
do collab with other brands because then
you're bringing their people into your
world and your people into their world
absolutely I think that's a great way to
do it absolutely totally agree so
Freight she asks how to do successful
collaborations on that front great
question so I would definitely say again
somebody picks somebody to class right
with whether it was a brand and
influencer or celebrity that is slightly
different to you but you have a similar
ethos or values to them and create a
product that you know is different from
what you currently offer I don't think
you should offer a product that you
ready offer it just like repackage it
I've seen that happen before and I think
that it's usually not something that
does very well the performance is
usually quite poor and you're just
relying on their audience to sell the
product which is not ideal I think
create something new a new formula and a
shade and new cuts if you're talking
about fashion whatever it is create
something new together I think they take
a lot longer to do
when it's a new product any formula but
I think that's where you create magic
cult worthy limited-edition
collaborations that you're gonna see a
huge impact in and you want it to be
cult worthy I think create less collabs
but make sure that every single person
wants to buy it and they're gonna want
to collect it even if they're not gonna
use it they're gonna want a piece of
that you know magic that you created
with that person um to keep forever I
think do less but do powerful
collaborations yeah and I think Mona is
pretty clear that there's a common theme
and in a lot of what you're mentioning
which is like authenticity and being
genuine and and again you're spot-on
that it has to do with those collabs as
well and really figuring out first you
gotta figure out who you are as a brand
in who you are as an individual etc and
then find out there's so many other
brands that are gonna have the same kind
of goals mission meaning purpose that
you do and then you follow everything
that Mona just mentioned in terms of
doing something that's actually unique
for the both of you and maybe finding
that middle space that brings you
together absolutely
so Collier D'Amato asks influencer
marketing for service based businesses
so is it impactful basically I guess is
the question how effective can it be to
leverage influencers to sell services I
think it depends on this service based
business so if I was a kind of like very
small service business like a local kind
of salon or restaurant I would rather go
with a very micro influencer to promote
products somebody who I knew is based in
the area and somebody who I knew would
have maybe a more deep reach in that
area because I think when you go with
global influencers you're of course
gonna have to pay a lot more for them to
promote your service and then the the
return is so limited because you only
have a few locations but I think that
you know for a huge global global
service industry brand I think it's
worth it but for a small local brand I
think go to somebody who you know in the
area who maybe has a smaller reach but
it's very it's very saturated in your in
your area
city or wherever you are and I
definitely think it's worth it for sure
it's awesome
Shawn Thomas asks what if you're not
that great on the social media side but
really good on the business side um I
don't know if I fully understand the
question so like if you as an ear
starting a company you're really good on
the business side you're not that great
on the social media side what do you do
I think um you know hopefully you can
find people to work with you who are
really good at it you can always watch
people online there's so many great
people who are sharing advice people
like yourself like Gary who are sharing
great content and I think just learn
from them and I really am a big believer
of just we have a saying in Arabic it's
a hadouken fear etiquette means that
with movement there's blessing so I
think just keep doing you know don't
don't overthink it too much I think just
put keep putting things out there learn
from it put things out there learn from
it so don't doubt yourself too much and
don't don't stress yourself out too much
just keep going and try things out and
experiment and I think that's the best
way to learn and that's the best way for
you to become an expert right it's just
about practice so keep going that's good
jinwu a friend of the show's asks
thoughts on subscription box model in
the beauty space um I think they're
wonderful I think they're wonderful for
brands as well because truthfully from a
brand perspective it's always a great
way to to offload stock and it's also a
great way to get your your products in
the hands of customers who probably
wouldn't buy your product I think a lot
of subscription box customers just love
their subscriptions and they're not as
likely to go out and buy a huge bag from
Sephora so it's a great way for them to
try your product in a fit with a profit
they'll buy it again and if they don't
it's okay because you're able to you
know just get your the product into the
hands of new customers that's awesome
Dustin let's get one more question from
Mona they're like one of their hundreds
of questions there everybody loves chat
in the comments as well
so we'll have to have you back on just
for a Q&A session so Rudy Elizabeth asks
I'm currently looking for influencers to
help me out have not gone far any tips
and reaching out um I'd love to know
what kind of business she has but I
would say just honestly go into their
DMS I think people are always a lot
nicer than they'd expect and start with
the micro influencers you know you can
start with people like you'd be so
surprised how much some people will only
have a couple you know tens of thousands
of followers they can have a huge impact
too and just start growing slowly you
don't have to target people who have
over a million followers or five million
followers start with micro influencers
it usually a lot more grateful for you
reaching out to and they're gonna give a
lot more of their themselves to
promoting your product in I think just
grow slowly that's awesome
Mona thank you so much for joining us it
was an absolute pleasure write this
again later so much and thank you
everyone for your questions and your
comments you guys are awesome thanks
everyone see you next time all right
much thank you